Now the answer we just calculated was very elegant.
We used the nice assumptions that the sun's rays arrive in parallel and the earth is a sphere.
We made some nice calculations involving the geometry and the trigonometry that we learned
but at the end of the day, if our answer doesn't stand up to reality, we need to start over.
Now let's see, how did Eratosthenes do against reality?
Well, his calculated circumference was 46,250 kilometers and we compare that
to the 40,000 kilometers that we currently know is the actual circumference of the earth.
Clearly he was off, but how much was he off by?
Can you think back to the beginning of the unit and tell me what was Eratosthenes'
percent error in this calculation?